add bouche it covers the Steelers for
the Pittsburgh post-gazette kind enough
to join us I'm sure a busy day
Edie what's next in this situation you
know Dan I'm just trying to write
something about that
you know Bell can come in at any time up
to ten weeks and sign is franchise
tagging aid they'd have to take them
unless they're gonna rescind it and
they're not going to do that but with
what his teammates the way they reacted
yesterday wonder what that whole thing
is going to be like if he joins them
anytime soon and you know they have to
they have to start using them yeah that
was what was surprising it's rare when
players talk about other players
teammates money they may say it
privately privately but not publicly and
here you have the offensive line I'm
curious if Mike Tomlin is you know is
there a moratorium on this topic do you
think today that when you guys get a
chance to go in and talk to the Steelers
is anybody talking about what they were
talking about yesterday well won't be
for another hour till we can go in there
Dan but I think most of these guys are
gonna say hey look we said what we said
yesterday and that's going to be it I
mean I've been allowed around these guys
long enough these offensive linemen have
been here forever and I just think
that's what how they will approach it
but they were angry because they they
believed he was going to come in and now
that he's holding out it's it's it's
throwing a wrench into their offense a
guy like Ramon Foster who they're their
starting guard here for a long time is
32 going into the last year of his
contract this may be his last chance to
try and win a Super Bowl and he believes
his his teammates hurtin that what's the
likelihood of the Steelers trading lady
on them well the problem there is no
other team can give him a long-term deal
that's part of the whole thing if he's
traded if they pulled the franchise tag
he'd become a free agent you make any
kind of deal he wants but if they trade
him and of course he'd have to sign a
deal
and then trade I'm so he'd have to have
something worked out with his new team
and you know maybe they can get a wink
when you you know hey we'll we'll do
this for you next year but I don't know
in this league if if you know if he gets
hurt or something else they're not gonna
sign him to a big deal next year that
team if it's a devastating injury so
there's no guarantee for him that way
either
so I don't see a trade Dan could you see
a scenario where he sits out for nine
games and then says hey I'm gonna show
up and then the Steelers say no we're
good without you
Le'Veon then that screws up free agency
for him doesn't it well not really
because he would be an ottoman even
become an automatic free agent and
that's still only a little bit more than
half the season I'm sure there's a team
out there who would be willing to give
him a long-term deal starting right now
you know what I mean let's say a
contending team like around all the
49ers who need a running back you know
they could sign them for five-year deal
for blah blah blah and that would be
that and then push for the playoffs this
year maybe he's the final piece that can
that can do that what if James Connor
plays well you are thinking like the
rest of us Dan that of course is their
hope now and actually Ramone foster said
this the guards that this coming
yesterday what if were eight no and he
comes in and and and Connor is playing
great what do we do you know we can't
we're not going to change everything for
him I think he would either be the
backup or they would have to decide
right then and there if they want to
then pull the franchise tack you know
this is my problem with the Steelers
head and you've been around there a long
time
this this team finds drama or drama
finds it right yeah it's every year that
just feels like that they just do it
they almost self implode there
just something about it I don't know if
it's if it's Mike Tomlin or it's been or
if it's just because you have that you
know one of the steadiest ownerships in
NFL history but it just feels like
there's no trickle down here yeah last
year was a big drama year and we're off
to a fast start you know it's it's it's
one thing I mean maybe the Steelers
should never have tagged him I think
probably they look back they would have
been better off signing another veteran
running back using that money find an
inside linebacker
in free agency which they desperately
needed and that drafter running back say
delay me on hey thanks for your efforts
but we're using this fourteen and a half
million on in these other areas I think
they would have been better off doing
that but it goes back to Dan Rooney
saying he wishes he would have never cut
Franco Harris
even though Franco was in his waning
days they don't like to get rid of great
players and I think that that was the
bottom line here is there tension like
can you feel it when you're in the
locker room around this team you could
yesterday those linemen were hot the
embers are still burning in there Dan in
the locker room yeah they were they were
not happy I've I've only seen that once
or two other times one or two other
times one was last year when James
Harrison signed with the New England
Patriots after he allegedly kind of
forced the Steelers to cut him but he
was gone by that this is a this is a
teammate who still may come into that
locker room have fun today ed we
appreciate your time all right thanks
for having me on Ed Musha it covers the
Steelers the Pittsburgh post-gazette for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]